ton
un écrin de verdure discret comme un
joyau à l'abri des regards le domaine de
madame elisabeth 8 hectares de jardins
romantiques au coeur de la cité royale
pour sa première participation au rendez
vous aux jardins et paroles de jardinier
il se dévoile aux visiteurs des
animations culinaires des animations de
décoration florale mais également des
producteurs et des pépiniéristes des
yvelines avec bien entendu une touche un
petit peu sucré avec des produits un
producteur de miel et de l'éco pâturages
donc beaucoup d'animations pour petits
et grands
j'ai toujours une pensée assez douces
pour madame elisabeth qui était un
personnage qui vivaient dans ce dans ce
mot domaine qui comme vous le savez
était la soeur cadette de luis elle elle
était très amoureuse de la nature donc
ça sera notre marraine pour ces deux
jours là un domaine sans pesticides
depuis plus de dix ans les jardiniers
s'engage dans le respect de la nature
ils feront découvrir leur travail avec
un détour par l'orangerie et son
laboratoire d'expériences en plein air
un vivier de plantes aromatiques
tout est comestible dans quasiment
jardin ce ce qui est appréciable c'est
qu'on peut manger donc du jardin à
l'assiette quasiment donc on prend une
plante on la goûte on la savoure on en a
l'eau d'heure il y aura une association
qui fera découvrir des tisanes comment
on pourrait faire avec son jardin des
tisanes personnel donc avec une culture
avec une cueillette sur place et après
une préparation en salle se soigner
grâce à la sauge ou à la mélisse un
privilège royal désormais accessible à
tous l'orangerie ouvrira également sa
première exposition sur les jardins
connecter à découvrir dès les 3 et 4
juin